Caption: hi i'm jason and welcome to my
Caption: presentation let's build a cowplay app
Caption: i'm a senior developer at adapter a
Caption: mobile centric dev house based right
Caption: here in perth
Caption: i'm also a volunteer instructor at
Caption: rockingham dog club i like to talk
Caption: training as a hobby and have started
Caption: competing in obedience and jumping with
Caption: my cocker spaniel layer
Caption: first of all i'd like to take a moment
Caption: to thank our sponsors for giving me the
Caption: opportunity to speak today
Caption: on this slide we have a photo of the
Caption: wilson parking app running on carplay
Caption: this is the second parking app in the
Caption: world
Caption: it was so close to being the first
Caption: i implemented this functionality and
Caption: during this presentation i am going to
Caption: show you how to build a carplay app
Caption: most new cars have started supporting
Caption: carplay
Caption: this integrates your iphone's operating
Caption: system with your car's infotainment
Caption: system the touchscreen in your car
Caption: once you plug your iphone in to your car
Caption: via usb
Caption: a carplay version of the iphone's
Caption: operating system will be displayed on
Caption: your car's touchscreen
Caption: this will only include apps which
Caption: support carplay
Caption: i personally use spotify and maps most
Caption: of the time when i'm driving
Caption: there's a single app which runs on your
Caption: iphone
Caption: carplay is treated as an external
Caption: display
Caption: and has its own ui independent of the
Caption: iphone's ui
Caption: all the processing is still done on the
Caption: iphone
Caption: carplay is an apple system and will only
Caption: work with iphones
Caption: android has a different system called
Caption: android auto this presentation is
Caption: focused on the apple carplay system
Caption: apple only allows a small handful of app
Caption: categories to support carplay originally
Caption: back in 2014 when one carplay first
Caption: launched
Caption: this was just audio navigation and
Caption: communication apps
Caption: last year as part of the ios 14 release
Caption: apple changed the way carplay works
Caption: and expand the supported categories to
Caption: include ev charging parking and quick
Caption: food ordering
Caption: most ui frameworks let you create
Caption: screens by nesting and arranging
Caption: components as you like in order to
Caption: ensure carplay apps remain safe to use
Caption: in the complex driving environment this
Caption: is a lot more restrictive
Caption: instead carplay apps
Caption: oh sorry i'll scratch that instead
Caption: carplay screens are created from a fixed
Caption: set of templates
Caption: there are some examples on this slide
Caption: and there are more available
Caption: the carplay app programming guide
Caption: contains documents all the templates
Caption: available
Caption: carplay apps decide when a template is
Caption: is displayed on the screen and what data
Caption: is shown the template handles everything
Caption: else
Caption: oh
Caption: sorry um
Caption: so i've just come back um
Caption: ah
Caption: all carplay apps will look and feel the
Caption: same
Caption: as templates provide no styling options
Caption: except in our cases this is great as all
Caption: carplay apps will um this is great as
Caption: you can achieve a lot with a small
Caption: amount of code
Caption: the downside is you can only do what the
Caption: templates provide
Caption: user input is also very limited in
Caption: carplay there there are no text fields
Caption: there is no keyboard
Caption: templates only provide pressable
Caption: controls like buttons
Caption: and siri can be used for more
Caption: complicated inputs
Caption: your carplay app will also determine
Caption: which templates it has access to some
Caption: templates like the list can be used by
Caption: all car players
Caption: other templates like the point of
Caption: interest can only be used by ev charging
Caption: parking and quick food ordering apps
Caption: the carplay app programming guide
Caption: will tell you which
Caption: templates your app has access to
Caption: templates only display a small amount of
Caption: information
Caption: for example this template will display a
Caption: maximum of 12 items each item will have
Caption: a title a subtitle and maybe an image
Caption: carplay uses a stack for navigation and
Caption: also limits the number of templates
Caption: which can go on the stack
Caption: the quick food ordering apps can only
Caption: have two templates on this stack whereas
Caption: all other carplay apps can have a
Caption: maximum of five templates on this stack
Caption: apple defines a bunch of guidelines
Caption: which ios apps must follow
Caption: when you have finished your app and are
Caption: ready to submit to the store apple will
Caption: check your app to ensure it follows
Caption: these guidelines if they think you have
Caption: breached a guideline your submission
Caption: will be rejected
Caption: carplay has its own set of guidelines
Caption: which must be followed
Caption: i will not bore you today by going over
Caption: all of the carplay guidelines
Caption: and instead have selected some of the
Caption: main ones which i'll go over
Caption: the best place to check all of these
Caption: guidelines is the carplay out
Caption: programming guide
Caption: the first one
Caption: essentially means
Caption: that your app must provide appropriate
Caption: functionality for its category
Caption: so a parking app is expected to provide
Caption: some sort of parking service
Caption: all carplay flows must be meaningful to
Caption: use whilst driving
Caption: apple doesn't apple only wants us to
Caption: include a feature in carplay if it's
Caption: called to the app and make sense to
Caption: perform whilst driving features like
Caption: maintenance unrelated settings and
Caption: filling out forms should be left to be
Caption: done on the iphone when it is safe to
Caption: perform these tasks
Caption: all carplay flows must be possible
Caption: without interacting with the iphone
Caption: templates do not provide the same
Caption: functionality as what can be done on the
Caption: iphone
Caption: you're not allowed to launch a screen on
Caption: the iphone to continue your flow instead
Caption: you have to look at either changing your
Caption: carplay flow so that it will work
Caption: entirely and carefully or remove that
Caption: feature from carplay
Caption: and finally you're not allowed to
Caption: instruct a user to to manipulate their
Caption: iphone to perform a task
Caption: and
Caption: you can quite common uh so um
Caption: common error conditions can easily be
Caption: resolved by performing a task on an
Caption: iphone for example
Caption: a user not being logged in you can
Caption: simply prompt the user to log in
Caption: on carplay you're not you are not
Caption: allowed to instruct the user to log in
Caption: instead you have to be clever about your
Caption: error message indicating something is
Caption: wrong without tempting the user to touch
Caption: their iphone
Caption: before we jump into the code i'm going
Caption: to go over the scope of the app we're
Caption: going to build today first of all we are
Caption: going to make a parking app
Caption: this is because we get access to the
Caption: point of interest template which is
Caption: flashy and great for a demo
Caption: we're going to need an iphone ui
Caption: in our case it's going to be very
Caption: complex and display hello world
Caption: our carplay ui is going to display us
Caption: car parks nearby allow us to select a
Caption: car park and navigate to a screen for
Caption: more information
Caption: before we can start creating carplay
Caption: functionality we first need an iphone
Caption: app
Caption: in our case we're going to use the one
Caption: auto generated by xcode using swift and
Caption: ios 14.
Caption: our appdelegate class has been already
Caption: generated for us
Caption: this manages the lifecycle of the app
Caption: and is the entry point for when the app
Caption: starts
Caption: all this does oh sorry well currently
Caption: all this does is return
Caption: our iphone scene configuration
Caption: will create this
Caption: scene delegate which manages the life
Caption: cycle of the iphone's ui
Caption: all this does is
Caption: create a window and populate it with the
Caption: content view which will display hello
Caption: world
Caption: this scene delegate currently uses a
Caption: swift window but we could change this to
Caption: use whatever technology your iphone ui
Caption: is rendered in
Caption: the wilson parking app uses react native
Caption: to render its iphone
Caption: ui
Caption: react native is a lot more complicated
Caption: to set up and if you would like
Caption: information about this i have written a
Caption: blog post which will be shared at the
Caption: end of this presentation
Caption: we have an iphone app let's start adding
Caption: some carplay functionality
Caption: carplay will be written in swift using
Caption: the carplay api
Caption: to build our carplay app we must first
Caption: specify an entitlement in order to use
Caption: carplay
Caption: create a carplay scene to manage the
Caption: lifecycle of our carplay ui
Caption: configure to configure our app to use
Caption: two scenes one for carplay and one for
Caption: the iphone and finally construct some
Caption: templates which will be displayed on the
Caption: carplay screen
Caption: in order to use carplay you need an
Caption: appropriate entitlement
Caption: each app category supported by carplay
Caption: has a
Caption: has an associated entitlement this is
Caption: because each car play entitled
Caption: this is because each carplay entitlement
Caption: unlocks different functionality from the
Caption: carplay api
Caption: first we must create an entitlements
Caption: file and specify our parking entitlement
Caption: like what is shown on the screen
Caption: in order to deploy to a device or the
Caption: app store
Caption: we need
Caption: and
Caption: we need the same configuration in an
Caption: associated apple developer account
Caption: common entitlements like camera access
Caption: can simply be configured
Caption: carplay is a lot more exclusive you must
Caption: first contact apple and apply
Caption: for the carplay entitlement as part of
Caption: this application process apple will
Caption: check your company
Caption: and the app being developed
Caption: when we were working on the carplay
Caption: functionality for the wilson parking app
Caption: we had to get wilson to apply for the
Caption: parking entitlement
Caption: apple could see that wilson is a parking
Caption: company they have a parking app and we
Caption: eventually got the parking entitlement
Caption: if your application is is successful you
Caption: can then
Caption: configure the entitlement through your
Caption: apple developer account
Caption: our project does not have an associated
Caption: so it will not be able to so it can only
Caption: run in the simulator environment
Caption: our carplay scene delegate manages the
Caption: lifecycle of the carplay ui all this
Caption: does is create our first template and
Caption: set it as through
Caption: our app delegate needs to change so that
Caption: when carplay connects we return the car
Caption: placing configuration otherwise we
Caption: return the iphone's same configuration
Caption: let's now have a look at making our
Caption: first screen
Caption: our first screen is going to show us car
Caption: parks nearby for the purpose of this
Caption: demo i have three markers on the map
Caption: which are three random locations sorry
Caption: can i start that bit um
Caption: i'll take that forward
Caption: let's first let's have a look at making
Caption: our first screen our first screen is
Caption: going to show us carpark
Caption: our first screen is going to show us car
Caption: parks nearby
Caption: for the purpose of this demo i have
Caption: chosen three random locations around
Caption: perth which you can see via the yellow
Caption: markers
Caption: to achieve this we are going to use the
Caption: point of interest template which has two
Caption: modes one mode shows us a list of point
Caption: of interest objects and another mode
Caption: shows us different data when a point of
Caption: interest has been selected
Caption: this code creates our point of interest
Caption: object
Caption: with three random locations around perth
Caption: with the aid of a helper method
Caption: sorry i'll just done that
Caption: this code creates our point of interest
Caption: template
Caption: with three random
Caption: carpark locations with the aid of a help
Caption: or function
Caption: our helper function simply creates a
Caption: point of interest object and returns it
Caption: this will add a button at the bottom of
Caption: our
Caption: point of interest object so that when it
Caption: is selected in the point of interest
Caption: template we will see more details which
Caption: will navigate us to the next
Caption: to the next screen
Caption: our next screen is going to show us more
Caption: specific information about a selected
Caption: car park
Caption: to achieve this we're going to use the
Caption: information template which is a couple
Caption: of items in the center of the screen and
Caption: a button at the bottom which takes us
Caption: back to the previous screen
Caption: this code creates our point of in our
Caption: sorry
Caption: this code creates our information
Caption: template
Caption: with our list of items displayed in the
Caption: center and our done button which takes
Caption: us back to the previous screen
Caption: let's now see this code running
Caption: on our iphone simulator we have the
Caption: carplay demo
Caption: app this doesn't have an icon because
Caption: i've just not set one up
Caption: when we press this we get our iphone ui
Caption: which will display hello world
Caption: on our carplay simulator when we press
Caption: our carplay demo app
Caption: we'll get our carplay ui
Caption: which displays our
Caption: screen containing car parks nearby you
Caption: can see the three markers
Caption: our list on the left containing three
Caption: car parks
Caption: we can select a car park showing us
Caption: different information about the car park
Caption: we can select more details which will
Caption: take us to the next screen showing us in
Caption: more information about the selected car
Caption: park
Caption: we can then press our done button which
Caption: takes us back to the previous screen
Caption: not everything can be tested in the
Caption: simulator environment
Caption: carplay functionality can differ on
Caption: actual car to play devices for example
Caption: in the demo you just saw
Caption: the information template shows the data
Caption: area on the left
Caption: and then it's um
Caption: on the screen we have a photo of the
Caption: wilson parking app which is also using
Caption: the information template which shows the
Caption: data area on the right
Caption: this is because
Caption: the photo is showing and showing an
Caption: australian carplay device
Caption: when developing the carplay
Caption: functionality for the wilson parking app
Caption: we had to test on
Caption: cars which supported carplay as well as
Caption: the carplay device which you can see on
Caption: the slide
Caption: if you would like to play further with
Caption: the demo you just saw you can download
Caption: it from my github
Caption: the carplay app programming guide
Caption: documents all the information you need
Caption: to build a carplay app
Caption: if you would like more information on
Caption: carplay development i've written a blog
Caption: post which is available here and finally
Caption: you should check out what my awesome
Caption: colleagues at
Caption: colleagues and i get up to an adapter as
Caption: we'll quite often feature book posts on
Caption: our website
Caption: thanks everyone that's the end of my
Caption: presentation